pearl do you think right what you just
said there do you think that
historical catastrophes must be
compensated for no no that's stupid
so then
i'm not saying i'm not agreeing or
disagree so then
how come
there were groups of people that got
compensation then
okay for instance like jewish people
chinese japanese people with the with
the with the bombs like there were
groups of people who got compensated i
don't know
so it wasn't fair what well i'm talking
about like when i when i think about
group i think about reparations
so i don't
i mean maybe if if the people were still
alive today like i don't know maybe
but
like when when you said historical i
thought you meant like at the past in
the present yeah so like in the past
people talk about slavery so in the past
you know the holocaust happened in the
past you know yeah japanese but people
got compensated for it yeah do you know
what i mean and i think accuracy one of
the things i think i think
it's a double-edged sword with a lot of
black people actually because you can
double us between victimhood and not and
it's like
it's like give us our money it's like
first of all i don't think reparations
is viable
first of all um i don't think any
country is going to [ __ ] their
economy for a bunch of people
i just don't believe that it's going to
happen um however do i think
given the um
[Music]
there's a book right called how the how
europe underdeveloped africa
and when you read that book you realize
that the whole industrial revolution and
stuff like that was started because of
the colonization and you just think um
well if you didn't if you didn't do that
then you wouldn't be as successful
so what do you mean by the colonization
so the colonization of africa so
both the people
and the resources right
there's a direct correlation between the
colonization of africa and the
industrial revolution okay and so with
all the metals and the
rubber and all this kind of stuff coming
from africa okay it fueled the
industrial revolution of the west wait
so
you're saying like in africa when you
say colonized you're saying like like
did england come in in colorado yeah
like so european france spain portugal
england and they like enslaved africans
and yes
okay so they
well they they enslaved at least
colonize the
the continent okay so
when you colonize a continent and then
you take
then you take ownership of the resources
you're able to gather those resources
together and use them to your own
benefit right and so you gather those
resources using your own benefit and
build up your economy right all the
while
messing up the economy of that actual
country right and so it's like
well would the west have been
as successful
well the problem is slavery happened
everywhere so you you could make that
argument with like everywhere across
history like arabs they're the worst
i was the first time we save african
people you know they they castrated they
castrated yeah and then and they still
do it to this day and oh shoot sorry and
um like the irish their indentured sir
france had a lower life expectancy than
slaves the yes and i hear people say
that and i do not disagree but
economies weren't made off of irish
um indentures i just don't know what
you'd like do about it today
like well that's why i said because it's
not it's not something that
can be quote-unquote rectifiers i think
the way in which to rectify it
personally
is for
black people to say okay cool it's time
for us to take control of our own
resources
oh so like just individualized thinking
oh no or just
self-determination oh yeah like everyone
needs to determine themselves oh okay do
you know what i mean i don't think like
asking for something that you're never
gonna get is yeah or but i don't even
think that would make sense if you were
like like if you're going to take money
from people that didn't do it and give
it to people that weren't alive for it
you know whatever you yeah but the thing
is i i get that but that's the thing
it's like
the the economy that we have today yeah
that's built off of it yeah do you know
what i mean so
this is the thing like people keep
saying well if your economy was built
off of it then there must be something
and i get the concept if you if you live
in this house
but your grandparents stole it off of my
grandparents yeah right yeah and then
this house is now a mansion
irish i didn't do it no i'm not i'm just
saying something it was that yeah and
then my grandchildren turn up to your
house like stop this house you're gonna
be like like uh well it happened right
you know i made it happen but right well
but then and the other issue is like
like it wasn't
like um like black people enslaved black
people too
so you know like a third out of freed
slaves in louisiana on slaves
i i i i hear that so the slave trade
was
was organized by europeans
no that's
not the ones that like captured them no
no because
there were many africans involved the
europeans couldn't survive in africa
they would get malaria yeah so they used
to use the african jews to go and get
them yeah and bring them yeah totally
agree yeah so it's like how would you
no that's what i'm saying
but i totally agree like you're always
going to get
people that are freaking traitors and i
don't know like people that you can pay
to do a job for you because but this is
what i'm saying it's like
i get the i what i'm saying is i get the
argument of
you i want that back i'm not saying
you're gonna get back though yeah i'm
just saying i get the argument
no i don't get it you don't get it
i mean maybe they'll probably say it's
because i'm white
so you don't get the argument of well i
just like my parents like i have one
grandparent from lithuania our
great-grandparent from like lithuania
i'm like lithuanian polish german and
irish oh so you're white white yeah yeah
like but you're like white white yeah
but i just don't like
like i'm just not that into those
cultures because i'm american and so i
just don't
really
know or care what happened back then
because i'm alive today no i get that
but the thing is
yeah i get it but i get what you're
saying but i think
if you take something from someone
uh-huh
and it's people have witnessed it yeah
and then they've seen you take that
money and build a whole empire with the
money that you stole yeah they're
they're what you their children are
gonna be like yo that's my father's
stuff yeah i mean i can make that
argument if it's like you're the person
that did it but like their grandkids
like what they didn't do anything
no they didn't yeah they didn't you
didn't do anything so that's what i'm
saying is it's not
realistic to expect them to give it back
right and you know what i'm saying it's
not realistic because they're gonna be
like well i didn't do it yeah but i
think the thing is is that
black because i've heard this argument
so many times with black person i think
black people understand
how the west was grown
what um what percentage of white people
in the us do you think owned slaves
probably less than five percent probably
um less than one percent that's the one
percent yeah it was like it was i don't
remember what the exact stat was but it
was like five percent like back then of
the cell
so and like most people in the us
immigrated after
so
because it was a slave owners
with the plantations because those
plantations were huge and those
plantations aren't owned by your average
white person no
get it no
okay let's view the situation at the
most fundamental level and group rights
are an absolute catastrophe in my
opinion well let's michelle come in on
that point
um the reason
the reason that trump and brexit in
britain and all kinds of nativists all
over europe is succeeding is not the
triumph of the right it's the
catastrophic failure of the left it's
our fault
we
absolutely
my point is not that i've turned to the
right or anything like that or that i'm
nice and fluffy and want everybody to be
decent i'm saying [ __ ] political
correctness resist
fight if you have a point of view fight
it in the proper manner using
democracies it should be not channels of
education not language
you know it's so silly
but there's a chess rule you know in
chess the best move to play in chess is
not the best chess move it's the move
your opponent least wants you to play at
the moment you're being recruiting
sergeants for the right but by annoying
and upsetting and instead of fighting
either fighting or persuading but
political correctness is a middle course
that simply doesn't work well first of
all
you said be empirical now empirical as
far as i know the word means that which
can be verified or falsified through the
census exactly so if we look at it in an
objective um a way
the reality is that people don't have
equal access to the means to articulate
the very moment you're talking about i'm
talking about the empirical results of
this political attitude i understand
that but my point is simply this i'm
suggesting to you that people use the
weapons at hand
now it was abraham joshua heschel the
rabbi who said everybody's not guilty
but everybody's responsible
right that's a distinction there
everybody clearly is not guilty but
what's interesting look at the flip side
if you have benefited from
300 years of holding people in servitude
thinking that you did it all on your own
why can't these people work harder let
me see for 300 years you ain't had no
job
so the reality is for 300 years you hold
people in the bands you hold them in
subordination you refuse to give them
rights then all of a sudden you free
them and say you're now individuals not
having the skills not having their own
not having skills i'm talking about
america first of all i'm some of the
american society first of all i'm
talking about the northern hemisphere
i'm talking about every society where
enslavement has existed but i'm speaking
specifically of the repudiation of
individual rights among people of color
in america who were denied the
opportunity to be individuals so i have
see i obviously and ideally close that a
second do you absolutely